STARTED.
GUESS WHAT, NUNES, MONTHS
LATER IS STILL WAITING.
PETE?
>> Pete: ED, THANKS.
A LOT THERE.
LET'S BRING IN A MEMBER OF
THE HOUSE JUDICIARY
COMMITTEE RON DESANTIS, A
REPUBLICAN FROM FLORIDA WHO
JOINS US FROM NAPLES TONIGHT
WHO IS ALSO RUNNING FOR
GOVERNOR IN THE FINE STATE
OF FLORIDA.
THANK YOU FOR BEING HERE.
I APPRECIATE IT?
>> THANKS, PETE.
YOUR CHAIRMAN IS NOT
SATISFIED WITH THE SPEED OR
VOLUME THAT THE DOJ PRODUCE
YOU HAD.
AS A MEMBER OF THIS ANY
TONIGHT WHERE ARE WE ON
WEATHER THEY NEED TO PRODUCE
DOCUMENTS.
>> THEY ARE DRAGGING THEIR
FEATS.
THEY HAVE BEEN DOING THIS
FOR A LONG TIME.
DEVIN NUNES ON THE INTEL
COMMITTEE.
HERE'S THE THING, PETE IF
YOU WERE THE SUBJECT OF
CIVIL ENFORCEMENT AND THEY
WERE SUBPOENAING DOCUMENTS
TO YOU, YOU WOULD NOT BE
ABLE TO GET AWAY WITH THESE
EXCUSES IF YOU WERE A
PRIVATE BUSINESS.
YOU WOULD HAVE TO PRODUCE
THE STUFF DOESN'T WORK THE
FORECAST HAS A DIFFERENT SET
OF RULES.
THE QUESTION IS ARE WE GOING
TO PUT THE MIGHT OF OUR
INSTITUTION BEHIND THESE
SUBPOENAS AND ENFORCE THEM.
YOU REMEMBER, WHEN THE IRS
WAS DRAGGING ITS FEET WE
HELD LOIS LEARNER CONTEMPT
BUT DIDN'T PHYSICAL THROUGH
WITH IT WE HAVE CERTAIN
TOOLS AT OUR DISPOSAL.
WE CAN USE THE POWER OF THE
PURSE AND HOLD OFFICIALS IN
CONTEMPT.
IF THEY'RE STILL INCALS
TRANT WE CAN IMPEACH CIVILES
OFFICERS.
WE HAVE TO BE WILLING TO DO
THAT.
OTHERWISE ANY WILL RUN OUT
THE CLOCK ON THIS STUFF.
>> Pete: HAVE YOU
REPRESENTATIVES, POLITICAL
APPOINTEES IN THESE
DEPARTMENTS APPOINTED BY
PRESIDENT TRUMP.
I ACTUALLY HAD THE
OPPORTUNITY ABOUT AN HOUR
AGO TO SPEAK TO A SENIOR DOJ
OFFICIAL INVOLVED IN THESE
MATTERS THEY POINT OUT A
COUPLE I WILL OF THINGS,
THIS IS THE FIRST WEEK SINCE
THEY HAVE DOUBLED THE AMOUNT
OF AGENTS.
THEY ARE TRYING TO PUT THE
PEDAL TO THE MEDDLE.
THEY ALSO NOTE THOOD
THOUSAND PAGES WILL BE YOUR
COMMITTEE ON MONDAY.
JUST SENT A LETTER TO DEVIN
NUNES SAYING THEY ARE GOING
TO ACOME INDICATE HIS
REQUEST FOR OTHER MEMBERS
OUTSIDE THE COMMITTEE TO
REVIEW THE FISA APPLICATION.
IF MORE PEOPLE CAN SEE THOSE
FISA APPLICATIONS AND MORE
DOCUMENTS ARE BEING
PRODUCED, DO YOU FEEL LIKE
YOU COULD GET TO A PLACE
WHERE DOJ IS ACTING IN GOOD
FAITH.
THEY'RE JUST HAVEN'T HAD THE
RESOURCES TO DO IT?
>> HERE IS WHY I'M SKEPTICAL
OF THAT I HOPE THAT'S RIGHT
AND THE AMERICAN PEOPLE GET
WHAT THEY ARE ENTITLED TO.
REMEMBER WHAT NUNES HAS BEEN
TRYING TO GET.
HE HAS BEEN TRYING TO GET
THOSE INITIAL DOCUMENTS
ABOUT HOW THIS WHOLE RUSSIA
CO-COLLUSION WITH TRUMP
CAMPAIGN NARRATIVE STARTED
FROM THE FBI.
THEY WON'T GIVE THAT TO HIM.
THAT'S NOT A MILLION
DOCUMENTS.
THAT'S THE SOMETHING THERE
IS PROBABLY ONE PIECE OF
PAPER THAT OFFICIALLY OPENED
THIS INVESTIGATION.
HE HAS BEEN ASKING FOR
MONTHS.
THE LAST SIX TO EIGHT MONTHS
HAS BEEN ONE OF CONTINUALLY
FRUSTRATING CONGRESS'
PREROGATIVE TO GET THESE
ANSWERS TO THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE.
>> Pete: GET US UNDER THE